but the thing is you haven't faced  adversity together and that is the  problem you're not facing your adversity  together I'll say it one more time you  are not facing the adversities together  and that is the problem I I'm listening  to you and I respect that you're you've  been so open because it's allowing me to  understand your story and I can see your  making effort yeah but you are it's like  you're missing the part where you have  to work as a team and that teamwork  means you have to put I to the side and  make it we are no no no no  I mean you can call him yeah listen I  wish he was here  I wish he was here because again this is  exactly you can be virtual no this is  yeah this is exactly the conversations  I've had with him yeah and I've told him  we're here we could do it this and that  again I can't change him if